how's it goin right hope you had a good
week having a good wakin I don't [ __ ]
know and not been doing what this guy is
doing it's drinking is bad especially
dancing with your bottle never what the
[ __ ]
and he come from all right let's let's
just go on a date for this [ __ ] what
are you talking about hey and you are
three minutes late no we did it
that [ __ ] we did no we really didn't
but look I remembered how much you like
flowers say oh that's how you get the
lady that was Darby well he probably
probably yeah hope something important
happened like he's dead because
otherwise there's no excuse did you say
you're waiting for Darby
yes I don't really like him but he's my
cousin and our family wants us to get
married well you know keep up the
tradition wait no your cousin you know
it used to be brother and sister until
it was maybe really now he's humiliated
so so say you and away leave Darby to
another cousin great you know I'll meet
you at the carnival tonight Jimmy I'm
really starting to like you oh [ __ ] that
and meet up with pinky at Billy's I
gotta meet up with that [ __ ]
all right look at this boy yeah boy yeah
on that oh sorry man sorry man sorry man
all right we got to hurry up in time
we're going to the carnival
we going to the carnival I don't run
what rhymes with Carnivale so I'm just
gonna say another word that rhymes with
Carnivale trying to still to think god
damn it I can't think of anything sorry
alright let's go in here alright right
the carnival did I make it in time crazy
[ __ ]
that's crazy [ __ ] I think you meant
whoa uh-huh I love fun don't you love
fun you hate fun I can look at you
no I'm just kidding you love fun or do
you a teddy bear you're easily swayed by
okay sounds like it uh what is this
strike out what the [ __ ] that guy looks
like it's gonna take a [ __ ]
don't wait yes I do
this is more fun yep a shot
oh no that is [ __ ] alright imma try this
again strike on that bench steer who am
I supposed to hit
[Applause]
he's out yeah that's what I'm talking
about
that's it come on [ __ ] let's go later
you can suck on my pen because it's a
lollipop nice pants bro thank you you
are so kind there someone lost a leg
wait we're going in two separate ones
[Music]
I almost vomited yeah I got a G&G
collective buck up it's time to show off
my muscle breasts all righty then let's
do this oh this is gonna be good
well this got to be good swing to manage
a hearty cat all right
what yeah [ __ ] yeah that's how strong
yeah yeah did you see that [ __ ]
I got 6 out of 10 shut up what is this
splish-splash wonderful shut up man shut
up shut up shut up you look like you are
super small Oh bullseye [ __ ]
poor guy no I loved him
all right I need one more shooting range
why the [ __ ] not
alright this is going man enough all
right here we go have a gun not too
shabby
[ __ ] but I got 205 that gets to me three
tickets
alright let's gather that teddy bear
chicks dig telomeres
alright let me get you this Hey
all right second buy like a bunch of
awesome stuff I want that I want that I
want those 12 tickets oh my god I gotta
get 12 tickets all right well I gotta
get her a stupid beer I'm gonna look for
this later bro there you go [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] happened with their voice I
[Music]
really know what it what are you doing
all right I want to I want to see you
though if you I can get that [ __ ]
Best Buy I want that you guys 75 tickets
for the scooter all right well I'm gonna
try to win it so I'll see you see you in
a couple hours
all right breasts I played all night and
Jimmy's tired look at this [ __ ] I am 106
tickets holy [ __ ] I know I play that
much all right so you're mine why not
buy that [ __ ] white why can I not buy
it I did not spend like an hour to get
hundred and six tickets just so this guy
can tell me I can't buy them shut the
[ __ ] up and give me mine
[Music]
why not
what-o left alt what the hell did I just
buy yes all right now why what else I
bought that stupid watch all right I
hope I have enough for that stupid
[ __ ] hat now I don't know why I'm
bothering with this [ __ ] hey I do have
enough clown trousers or some incredibly
strange hat clown trouser hat clown hat
clown hat what are your breasts think
the Hat all right let me get the Hat
[ __ ] yeah what son of a [ __ ] all right
let me get my Vespa now I can access it
from any garage so I guess my my son
house has one so let's go there yeah
this present it no oh my beautiful match
yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] the police [ __ ] the puffins the
cops are after me I don't even give a
[ __ ]
[Music]
alright that was beautiful [ __ ] love
your Vespa
let's go in here alright the quest
continues I need to go upstairs I think
right yeah here it is so I try to do
like an hour ago turtle face mm do you
need an album aqua Barry sweater you can
buy that quebert sweater at the clothing
Fustat no [ __ ] man you should try the
new Walker berry best I guess I have to
honestly oh [ __ ] me I look so ugly all
right I gotta fit in so buy that [ __ ]
teaching your kids a lesson you have to
swear the clothes that everyone else
where'd to fit in [ __ ] goodbye and [ __ ]
yourself and we're going back
although he jumps up the Vespa alright
now we can finally continue with this
stupid-ass quest what's going up on I
hear the eggs okay that's a nice name
look there he is
I was wondering if you'd show up Hopkins
nice aqua berry sweater I'd say she you
look a bit like my gardener at home yeah
so Wes well enough about gardeners or
any domestic help listen me and the
chaps were planning a little revenge hit
on old hat trick uh-huh we don't like
what he did to that old sow Galloway a
chap could have a drink if he bloody
hell wants to so so my friend argue as
they say in sure are you English no I
just speak this way because I'm very
insecure
well at least - ah there is a self-made
man so I pretend to be old money but in
fact I'm really nouveau riche but less
about me dear boy listen we're going to
egg that old codgers house cool smashing
you go get some eggs and meet me in the
chaps back at my house this explains
everything [ __ ] love the characters
in this game so I don't know kind of
miss Gary honestly even though is
[ __ ] annoying that's Mike what the
hell is going on what why didn't the
hell stuck in the door where's my rest
spot oh my Vespa was [ __ ] me over hey
perhaps even notice how much [ __ ] you
owe me
we need to go uh oh [ __ ] we need to go
far see you in a second brauch
oh yeah all right we're here I think
whoa and the slide that [ __ ] open
[Applause]
what's up noobs all right what's going
on got the eggs Hopkins yeah give him to
me
take them smashing now tell me Hopkins
is it sure you said I was inbred no
because first cousins is legal my friend
legal oh okay yeah and just because my
elder brother doesn't have a chain and
ended up in a lunatic asylum it doesn't
mean anything whatever your family is
your business
so my Jimmy I was the bad was probably a
hermaphrodite with that much in breed
her Matt for what
now what don't act dumb you said his mom
was also legally his aunt and that he
probably had webbed toes I don't well
just only on one foot you're not gonna
take that kind of crap from this scumbag
are you Youth you you've been rude about
mommy
oh no this papa no no Gary keeps [ __ ]
me over no no you're not stop stop stop
stop please stop
what retrieve the gate key yes I do wish
I had the case but I was [ __ ] you now
stop blocking
no you're not you're [ __ ] terrible I
got the key let's get out of here and no
one cares that I'm opening the gate eggs
are available in your room
god dammit I lost my prep a respect I
guess I never was a perfect captain
Jimmy Hopkins okay that's good I didn't
know about that we got a new quests it's
over there let's go and get it I don't
know how you ride a skateboard in sand
but I'm loving it but I pat pat pat all
right there's got to be a wardrobe over
here right yeah there it is all right
what do we got
wait you're wrestling it beautiful that
one is pretty cool though but this one
wins the prize here we are beautiful
gorgeous but you don't like the Hat you
told me to buy it you can't change your
mind now you love it say you love it
please that's better thank you okay
but this guy's doing this chilling at
the beach
all right we need to go back to Bulworth
I don't know why probably [ __ ] with Gary
or some [ __ ] but it's a start the valley
race valley all right I could do that
what's up Jimmy hey Pete Pete where's
everybody
Oh Jimmy it's you yeah guess you want to
kill Gary now that is true most of
school against you and got those rich
kids to throw eggs at you
Gary you'll get what's coming to him
what's wrong with you nothing yeah
sitting around watching TV by yourself
like a loser someone crap in your bed
what's wrong
well for one moment I had friends like
my hat I know that's my hat yeah Gary's
a snake and you're a psychopath
ah come both bullied me mercilessly but
Lisa wasn't left out but now back in my
own and I'm too cool to be a dork and
I'm too dorky be anything else you're
not on your own where is everybody at
the bike race at old Bulworth Vail by
shiny bikes at the beach my question why
didn't you say so
come on you don't you see my pimp act
please acknowledge my pimp at Kate you
can't hang with me if you don't
acknowledge my pimp I'd say is it uh get
a bike where okay that was easy
I don't really like the bikes but I have
a pin pad so it's okay
why am I so slow with these why like
seriously why am I so [ __ ] slow i
nerds what's up judge makes me lie look
at that
I don't even know where to go
alright alright alright alright I got
this just got to make sure I don't miss
all those [ __ ] oh I got a way lead
huh
[ __ ] not too easy I'm one second ahem
what am I going now the [ __ ] am i going
off for [ __ ] sake Jimmy there's only
one lab - [ __ ]
come on too much excitement [ __ ] [ __ ] I
clicked the wrong button
oh come on baby
it's a wide where now that guy behind me
it's [ __ ] up what the hell was it want
he wants to win the race [ __ ]
so tired of Clegg it's like a [ __ ]
workout oh oh no baby oh no baby not
today not today we're gonna win this
oh ah bang Oh night ba da ba da da da
night night Victor did I win Oh pin pad
to look at my boss we get sweet come
back any time
I'll have your trophy I hope it's not
his deck
[Music]
best down seven no stopping Jimmy hop
again yes you want to get a 70
dismantling every couple with a 767
Daniel
yes very expensive but it will make you
a machine fly that's not the pros -
really I was gonna get the 976 because I
thought it'd make me look important
amongst my peer group a 976 what are you
a girl the kid who won the race hey you
came for your trophy huh ya know here
she is beautiful [ __ ] it was actually
a total dick covered in aluminum wrap
with your hand
spelled on guys whose career aspirations
are to work in stores fabulous I love it
when people know their place in life my
toilet you trust fun turd do you even
have flushing toilets in your trailer I
couldn't imagine it you guys are a bunch
of scumbags aren't you got bring it come
on nice trophy hey let me see why did
you say my trophy with mine it's
misspelled name on it I gotta get my
trophy back others [ __ ]
step aside woman faster is it going in
my beach house why would he get rikiei
what the [ __ ] are you doing what are
they what are they well I'm gonna break
your balls they're gonna be break broken
out stop
[Music]
da ball the head triple net ball [ __ ]
[ __ ] ah [ __ ] sake my trophy yes this
falls down anyway
god damn I love this game alright I'm
done now I'm done now for today no
shopping when my penis pop it that was
great man hey you know what
go fish why am I giving this guy money
well [ __ ] it
alright so rich is following me now I
don't know why but yes and he's wearing
glass no it's a cigarette
is that a dead beer my okay good anyway
I hope you bros enjoyed I [ __ ] love
this game so much oh boy sorry dad like
if you did subscribe to come alright
there it is and I'll see you next
episode I haven't make
[Music]
alright it looks like someone [ __ ] on a
stick and send it here makes thank thank
you for doing that
[Music]